tengo este artículo sacado de web md
no quiero atacar la reputación de web de
md tienen muy buenos artículos y buena
información en su sitio pero la cosa que
yo quiero hacer aquí es pensar sobre las
noticias y la investigación que ustedes
leen porque puede ser que estén
implicando conclusiones que sean falsas
esto es un extracto de un artículo y el
título del artículo dice tomar el
desayuno puede combatir la obesidad en
adolescentes entonces ya están tratando
de crear una relación de causa y efecto
están están el mismo título dice si
ustedes desayunan entonces eres menos
propenso a
eres menos propio eres menos propensos a
ser obesos
aunque ya no vas a ser obeso entonces el
título prepara esto del desayuno y dice
que podría vencer la obesidad en
adolescentes se dice que en el estudio
publicado en pediatrics los
investigadores analizaron la dieta y el
peso de un grupo de 2.216 adolescentes
en 5 años de escuelas públicas de
mineápolis y no voy a hablar mucho de
esto realmente fue una buena muestra es
significativa y fue un largo tiempo ok
supongo que voy a suponer que
controlaron todas las variables y demás
pero luego dicen que los investigadores
escribieron que los adolescentes que
tomaban desayuno regularmente tuvieron
una un porcentaje menor de calorías
totales de grasas saturadas y comían más
fibra si carbohidratos que aquellos que
saltaron en el desayuno y esto es obvio
porque en el desayuno uno tiende a comer
cereal granos ya sabes no se va flesh
todos ellos tienden a estar en la
categoría de carbohidratos y azúcares y
francamente eso no es necesariamente
algo bueno necesariamente a lo mejor
bueno no sé no es obvio para mí cierto
si no es más saludable que los productos
o algo así ok después dice además el
desayuno regular parece ser parece ser
que hace más activos físicamente
aquellos que saltaron el desayuno
entonces dice aquellos que tomaban
desayuno regularmente bueno aquí no se
está implicando que el desayuno te hace
más activo
y en la última oración aquí dicen en el
tiempo los investigadores encontraron
que adolescentes que tomaban el desayuno
regularmente tendían a ganar menos peso
y tener una masa corporal menor que los
que saltaban el desayuno entonces nos
dicen que no desayunar es decir saltarse
el desayuno implica que es más propenso
a tener sobrepeso por no desayunar o
incluso que te haga obeso así que la
narración completa que va desde el
título hasta todo de hecho por todos los
párrafos dice mira desayunar te hace
activo no desayunar te hará obeso
desayunar no te hará obeso entonces
dices bueno debes pensar algo acerca de
los motivos y la industria relacionada
con el desayuno verdad esta
investigación nos dice que desayunar
previene la obesidad realmente nos dice
que desayunar hará que algunos se
vuelvan más activos nos dice que
saltarse el desayuno puede causar
sobrepeso realmente nos dice todo eso o
lo que es más probable nos muestran que
estas dos cosas tienden a ir juntas y
esta es una diferencia muy muy
importante y permiten establecer algunos
términos técnicos para esto que suelen
alomejor rebuscados pero que en realidad
no lo son y apuntan una la primera a la
causalidad
lo que lo que parece estar implicando no
por ejemplo desayunar no te hacer eso
entonces desayunar te hace activo y no
desayunar te hace obeso así que están
implicando causalidad causa-efecto están
implicando causa y efecto pero lo que en
realidad dice el estudio es correlación
así que el punto es entender la
diferencia entre causalidad y
correlación porque dicen cosas muy muy
distintas entonces tenemos causalidad
contra correlación por ejemplo entonces
causalidad te dice hay implica ve causa
be ok mientras que la correlación sólo
dice que ahí ve parece que aparecen al
mismo tiempo cada vez que ocurre tiende
a ocurrir junto con ve y la razón es que
si es importante distinguir entre estas
dos y es que puedes llegar a la
conclusión es muy muy muy diferentes
ok así que lo único que hace esta
investigación asumiendo que todo está
bien hecho es
es mostrar la correlación muestra que si
creemos todos sus datos que el no
desayunar se correlaciona con la
obesidad y que la obesidad se
correlaciona con no desayunar no por
ejemplo estar activo se correlaciona con
desayunar y al revés que desayunar está
correr correlacionado con no ser obeso
pero no dicen datos que me hagan decir
que algunas de estas condiciones implica
la otra baja por ejemplo están diciendo
que el desayuno causa actividad pero en
realidad podría ser podría ser que
realmente sea la actividad la que causa
que la gente desayuna quizá la gente que
es más activa es más propensa a tener
hambre en el día y quizá la actividad
causa el desayuno y ahora vas a empezar
a pedir otra comida y quizás digas bueno
quizás si eres activo y no desayunar no
digo que te lo preguntes quizás se
pierda más peso quizás hasta sea una
opción más saludable quién sabe no
estamos seguros lo que estoy tratando de
decir es mira si desayunas te vas a
hacer activo
el cual es un resultado bastante
positivo pero tal vez puedas tener este
resultado positivo aún sin desayunar
de igual forma dicen que no desayunar o
al menos están implicando que no
desayunar es causa de obesidad pero al
revés quizá la gente con alta masa
corporal por la razón que sea son menos
propensos a tener hambre en el día así
que esto puede que sea así que sea en
este sentido que la obesidad implique
que la gente se salte el desayuno verdad
lo cual puede que sea más probable
podrías pensar en un montón de ejemplos
diferentes como la actividad física la
actividad física y todas estas son
teorías no tengo pruebas de estos son
solo quiero dar una perspectiva
diferente acerca de los mismos datos y
de los mismos datos y no solo llegar a
la conclusión que ellos tienen que
parece que nos quieren convencer de que
desayunemos si no quiere ser obeso así
que quizás será físicamente activo te
lleve a tener hambre en el día
ok así que te puede que te lleve a tener
hambre en el día y lo más probable es
que desayuno y obviamente siendo
físicamente activo hace que quemes más
calorías y tendrás más musculatura y así
no serás obeso hay que notar que si
miras si miras las cosas de esta manera
por decir que la actividad física es la
causante de estas dos cosas y
repentinamente pierdes este vínculo
entre el desayuno y la obesidad ahora ya
no podrás decir que el desayuno es la
fórmula mágica para no ser una persona
obesa estás de acuerdo ya no es algo así
así que digamos que hay una persona
obesa digamos que la realidad es que la
actividad física es la causante de estas
cosas digamos que por ahí hay un obeso
que le puedes decir le dirás desayuna y
ya no vas a ser obeso bueno pues eso
puede que no les funcione sobre todo si
no son activos es decir qué pasará si
una persona obesa que no es activa tú
llegas y le dices que no desayune
qué pasa si le dices que no desayuné
puede que empeore la situación y basados
en esta que el consejo o la implicación
del artículo podría estar equivocado la
actividad física puede que sea lo que le
conviene a la persona tal vez es algo
distinto quizás a lo mejor debas dormir
tal vez la gente que se duerme hasta
tarde
se duerme tarde y no obtiene el descanso
suficiente
sin descanso
es lo que les lleva a la obesidad puede
ser y obviamente como no descansan lo
suficiente se despiertan muy tarde
tienen que correr a la cita correr a la
escuela en los que estudiamos y quizá es
por eso que no desayunan
y así que una vez más si ves a alguien
que es obeso la regla no es el meterles
el desayuno por la garganta tal vez eso
sea peor porque quizás sea por falta de
sueño lo que lo que causa que el
metabolismo sea más lento o qué sé yo
así que es muy importante que cuando le
demos un vistazo a este tipo de
artículos tratemos de decir si es
correlación o causalidad por ejemplo el
desayuno es lo que va a ser obeso a
alguien todo lo que te dice es que estas
dos cosas están correlacionadas de un
mejor estudio sería el que pueda probar
la causalidad de esto y podemos pensar
en razones más fundamentales que que más
o menos nos expliquen la narración que
este artículo está tratando de dar no
digo que esté equivocado
tal vez sea absolutamente cierto que
desayunando puedas evitarlo pero creo
que es igual lo más importante pensar en
que otras causas
tenemos de ambas ambas ambos fenómenos
así que por ejemplo la pobreza la
pobreza es causa de no desayunar debido
a múltiples razones tal vez sea porque
ambos padres trabajan no hay nadie que
sirve el desayuno no tal vez por estrés
en la familia quién sabe
quién sabe por qué será entonces cuando
eres pobre eres más propenso a no
desayunar
y cuando eres pobre tiene dos razones
los padres que trabajan los niños que
tal vez comen menos saludable quizás eso
comen menos al nou no comen de forma
saludable en todo momento lo cual les
lleva a la vez
a la obesidad así que una vez más en
esta situación esta es una realidad
posible el solo decirle a alguien que
desayune digamos aunque sea fútbol oops
y eso es muy probablemente no lo ayude
quizá la mala alimentación sea la causa
fundamental
ok la mala alimentación puede ser
y si comes una cena no saludable tal vez
para el desayuno aún no tengas hambre
verdad y entonces vas a hacer digo eso
porque te diste un atracón en la cena y
por lo tanto no vas a desayunar y eso
también te lleva a la obesidad pero otra
vez esta es otra realidad en donde sigue
el consejo del artículo puede que sea
malo si comes en una cena no saludable y
luego le entras al desayuno a la fuerza
sin tener hambre eso puede hacer la
obesidad aún peor el punto del vídeo no
es el decir que las implicaciones de
este artículo están equivocadas pero lo
importante es darse cuenta que pueden
que estén equivocadas y sólo por haber
visto la correlación de los datos no
significan que el desayunar mágicamente
combatirá la obesidad